j'accueille éric gagné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
kite acheter
[Musique]
je ne te laisserai pas vraiment pas là
je vous ai donné rendez vous à tout à
l'heure un des dix ans quitte ce matin
on va déjeuner en rien tous ensemble et
le curling non mais il n'y a personne
sur le plateau en face
je me suis dit vont être en retard
beaucoup d'électeurs n'a envie c'est
d'aller là-bas la pma soir pour pouvoir
donner le soir les gens allez venez avec
moi alors vient dé ma bande on va passer
une après-midi d'enfer comme la matinée
d'ailleurs on a bien démarré donc à
présent temps s'arrête voilà vous mettez
tous autour le moins ça va bien on sait
faire poser un appétit thiès là alors
c'est terminé maintenant permet de
connaître reste à l'intérieur et on
s'éclate avec eric et toi et moi
vingt ans plus tard tout le monde en a
parlé à retrouver eric galliano à plus
de 300 kilomètres de la capitale il vit
aujourd'hui à besançon dans l'est de la
france
loin du club dorothée des émissions pour
adolescents éric lenfant du petit écran
a pris de la maturité
il vit aujourd'hui d'une passion qu'on
ne lui connaissait pas la chaussure j'ai
toujours aimé les fringues les
chaussures j'ai toujours été lancés dans
cette ambiance là ça a toujours été
quelques chose que j'ai mis énormément
aimé j'ai toujours été attiré par ça
qu'il faut pas hésiter à porter haut la
main dîner plutôt slim le mettre à
l'intérieur
eric a pris ses cliques et ses claques
pour vivre de la chaussure et d'amour
avec jean-marc son compagnon j'ai
rencontré
[Musique]
donc sans marque à paris
il ne parlait de besançon dont je
connaissais pas du tout la vie au début
de notre rencontre s'est beaucoup lui
qui est monté sur paris après j'étais
très curieux de voir où on est et où il
vivait sa famille ses amis qu'il ya donc
je suis venu j'ai dû venir trois
week-ends ici et puis
le dernier week end c'est le dernier
quinté dijoux dizaine de jours je suis
jamais repartie et voilà maintenant ça
fait s'attend donc c'est une histoire
d'amour qui m'emmenait ici deux modèles
tu vois il vaut mieux que tu buzz
l'éclair en disant voilà sur cette
histoire comme ça mais il faut que tu
les laisses se décide et ouais ça sympa
il habille ses liens converti on va dire
c'est une belle histoire une belle
histoire
il a bien changé mais bon on a quand
même à la fin quand même sonner nouveau
sac et bien
bon lien gtc ouais on va aller retrouver
nous jean-marc sur eux marco
eric a laissé ses goûts de luxe à paris
et profitent aujourd'hui pleinement des
choses simples comme les voitures
anciennes
et les balades sur les bords du doubs
mais il n'oublie pas paris alors en fait
moi j'aime bien ce côté là de besançon
parce que ça me fait penser avec les
deux pieds de chaque côté peut-être
c'est encore plus le soir une fois
qu'est la lumière au centre y penser un
petit peu ou qui la mégisserie à paris
et que j'aime bien la pression à la
maison si en même temps
aujourd'hui éric et a tiré un trait sur
son passé de vedettes pour autant sa
reconversion n'a pas été facile
d'utilisation les plateaux télé l'ex il
l'expliqué par la suite il était habillé
par des marques il a toujours été
habitué
être à l'écran
à représenter des marques aussi
indirectement donc je pensais aussi
certainement de là que lui vient à la
passion distinguer de la mode quoi et
voilà donc ça c'est fait
j'irai naturellement non mais c'est vrai
que c'est reconversion qui
colle à la réalité simple et qui a été
violente aussi produit je pense mais
j'ai compris après
quand le rideau s'est baissé l'entourage
d'eric s'est détourné de lui alors à
besançon dans son nouveau chez lui il
s'est empressé de reconstruire autour de
jean-marc une bande d'amis
s'énoncer dernière à la
[Musique]
baillerie que oui animateurs oui c'était
la joie de vivre les gars sont contents
savent pas qui je vais essayer de vous
trouver des photos mais s'est enfoui
dans la cave donc je suis vraiment pas
sûr d'arriver
à trouver quoi que ce soit en fait je
regarde très très rarement pour pelé
jamais je devrais dire jamais tout ce
qui c'est quand ce
qu'elle cdh et ça je regarde jamais j'ai
même pas que jean-marc donc les années
j'ai tout ça dans ma tête et j'ai pas
besoin c'est vrai de regarder donc c'est
un capharnaüm monumental six bougies
j'arrive 1 s'est caché derrière la porte
du coin
[Musique]
j'ai pas interférer aux énormes battu un
perfecto qu'il va sans foi
ses parents parce que moi je regarde ça
avec j'arrose comme je suis pas
nostalgique je fais pas le syndrome des
mecs qui passent pas l'antenne tu vois
ces pages par ont fourni en disant oh
c'est dommage et ça me manque et cetera
je regarde ça aide énormément tendresse
et ça me rappelle plein de sous lire
plein de belles choses et des des super
moments la télévision une page qu'eric
n'a pas complètement tournée
mais la télévision ne propose pas
l'émission dance il ya un jour on
propose autre chose une émission de
télévision là des choses comme ça qu'on
verra
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
eric galliano bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue
dont tout le monde a parlé avec merci
alors vous êtes né le 12 juillet 1965 à
marseille il perd commercial mère
institutrice et directrice d'école
enfance sans problème oui dans un petit
village entre aix et marseille c'est
cabriès oui voilà vocation précoce
voulait devenir comédien croit au départ
je voulais devenir vétérinaire et puis
très vite
oui je j'ai dit à mes parents que je
voulais être comédien et puis me disais
pas d'accord à part ça c'est pas faire
alors pour assurer vos parents quand
même vous passez un cap2 prothésiste
dentaire
vous passez aussi le bafa et vous partez
travailler comme j au club med à montner
vous n'êtes pas parti d'un an maintenant
je suis pas parti très très loin c'est
pas le bout du monde en salle et ensuite
je vais vous perfectionner dans la
compagnie de michel fugain à nice ont
fait de la danse du chant et du théâtre
au même endroit donc voilà j'ai passé
les auditions j'étais pressée ça a
commencé comme ça ensuite vous essayez
un peu au café-théâtre ont fait des
sketches avec des copains justement de
l'atelier du gué en sortant de là on
joue dans des bars des cafés des choses
comme ça la vie du comédien qui démarre
ce mois
alors on est potes pas question de faire
de la télé d'ailleurs vos profs vous le
déconseille
mais comme au plan de comédiens tombe à
l'eau vous faites un casting organisé
par tmc je me suis bon match au casting
ça te fera un training donc j'y suis
allée comme si j'allais
à la boulangerie acheter des croissants
vous trouvez pas bon catastrophique mais
vous gagnez voilà oui on avoue devenu
speakrin oui sur tmc oui ça du rec 2
janvier h1 et donc je présentais le
programme je leur ai demandé si je
pouvais faire des sketchs en même temps
parce que donc comme je sortais lattes
et michel fugain c'est je trouvais ça
sympa de pouvoir dont tu vas plus quand
on a 20 ans pour toujours très drôle
très puis moi j'aimais bien ça alors
c'est acté fr vous remarque à 25 ans
vous faites deux premières grandes télés
avec danièle gilbert dans les grandes
oreilles oui il fallait reconnaître des
sons mais voilà c'est un petit jeu sans
prétention mais je pense que l'ambiance
était là alors votre dynamisme et votre
jeunesse plaisent beaucoup vous
enchaînez avec des pas 4 c'est mieux le
matin surtout l'après midi donc ça
commence à très bien oui j'arrive est-ce
qu'à l'époque j'ai le sentiment de vous
embarquer dans un truc qui est pas votre
chemin ou au contraire vous en prenez
votre parti au nom japon en partie parce
qu'à partir du moment où on voit là j'ai
compris que la télévision ne me plaisait
j'aimais beaucoup ce que je faisais
jamais fait les choses en reculant à
contrecoeur en même temps ça allait très
vite j'avais beaucoup d'antennes dire
que c'est le seul à avoir deux émissions
par jour enfin william hague y arriver
oui c'est en direct
mon épouse donc
venait d'accoucher aussi donc c'était
assez compliqué à gérer comme on a 20
ans et pas toujours évident mais voilà
j'ai essayé de gérer ça le mieux
possible en 1988 quand max meynier à un
accident cardiaque vous le remplacer au
pied levé et l'audience explose
carrément oui en fait moi le jeu je
l'avais vu qu aux etats unis ma femme
est éteinte américaine avec un animateur
hystérique comme j'étais plutôt dix
jeux les animer
la façon dont je l'avais vu ferment aux
états unis alors que max était plus tous
quelqu'un de 2 cuil plutôt bon papa se
sont sympas oui voilà c'est ça c'était
bon enfant s'est du coup le l'audience a
exposé parce que j'allais chercher les
gens dans le public accepte donc vous
devenez monsieur juste prix tf1 vous
fait comprendre que la place de max mini
est à prendre oui hélas vous refusez là
je refuse parce que j'avais max meynier
donc qui m'appelait 200 bd pital qui me
disait je te remercie vraiment eric
c'est très sympa d'avoir
repris les missions au pied levé ça va
mieux j'ai bientôt pouvoir mire et de
l'autre côté j'ai tf1 qui me dit max
méline ne reviendra jamais c'est toi qui
va regarder l'émission et là je leur dis
c'est pas possible moi je suis papa
faire ça et patrick roy acceptable alors
maîtres du moment que je leur ai dit que
j'ai dit non à tf1 moi je m'accrochais
métaux de chou parce que voilà j'étais
pendreff je leur disais non moi j'aime
et tokyo je suis parti en vacances aux
etats-unis et tf1 a supprimé donc les
tox coût de la grille en se disant de
toute façon quand il va rentrer il aura
pas le choix et quand je suis rentré
têtu comme une mule j'ai dit non je ne
ferai pas le juste prix donc ils ont
proposé à patrick roy qui a fait ça
remarquablement vous aviez plus de tokyo
j'avais plutôt que j'y peux rien là vous
passez sur france 2 oui ça repart de
plus belle mais l'animateur des
émissions jeunesse septier larmes en
titre au t2 baho dénoncer directement
embauchés pour six mois et puis après ça
s'est prolongée et puis après c'est
marie-france brière qui est arrivé est
là tout a explosé alors cette célébrité
été agressée rapidement finalement oui
assez vite revenir on va dire en vous
voyez de trois ans c'est ça oui quelles
ont été les réactions de votre entourage
très bonne et très très content pour moi
j'ai toujours eu les mêmes copains chez
toi j'ai essayé au maximum de garder les
pieds sur terre et puis dès que je
décolle un petit peu de toute façon il
avait toujours un qui se chargeait de me
ramener vos parents vous en face hier -
ma mère a un peu fait la gueule au
départ parce que j'étais pas prothésiste
dentaire ça s'était très bien c'est un
bon travail
et puis après le jour où donc j'étais
pris à télé monte-carlo elle m'a
téléphoné donc le soir ensuite elle
était en larmes et elle m'a dit je fais
dix ans de moins vous avez de l'argent à
l'époque j'ai gagné pas mal d'argent à
l'époque où j'ai gagné pas mal d'argent
je me souviens alors mon premier contrat
avec tf1
donc quand j'ai fait les grandes
oreilles j'étais lessive avec une
production donc j'étais payé je crois
peut-être dix mille francs à l'époque et
puis
tf1 me convoque et là je comprends qu'on
va me proposer un contrat d'exclusivité
et je me dis je me laisserais pas à moi
je me laisserais pas avoir ces 15 bis
n'ont rien du tout vu et là j'arrive
donc bio tf1 où on me passe sous de la
brosse et cetera eric êtes formidables
et je me disais basiques aux ges assange
ne serait pas avoir on vous veut en
exclusivité une exclusivité ça se paye
50 mille francs par mois à l'ag
comprends rien du tout parce que voilà
je sortais de télé monte-carlo c'est au
cachet
et là j'étais abasourdi et puis après
sur france 2 c'est un petit peu plus à
l'époque oui quand j'avais beaucoup
d'émissions dont beaucoup d'antennes
oui je devais gagner dans les enfants
c'était à l'époque dans mais il ya des
moments où j'ai gagné pendant les 90
francs
c'était bien de quoi vivent fin de vos
jours sans rien fait non non non voilà
je vous avais tout dépensé au fur et à
mesure et j'ai mis de côté jusqu'à
l'appartement après je l' ai je l'air
fondu parce qu'après on se sépare avec
mon épouse et puis donc voilà on est
comme elle est repartie aux états unis
donc l'argent est parti dans moi j'ai
tenu pour essayer de ne pas faire tout
et n'importe quoi avec cet argent l'un
est ce que votre divorce donc avec la
maman de mélissa est ce que c'est dû à
votre activité à la télévision elle est
le visage un peu assez mal au niveau de
l'humour le second degré il avait
beaucoup de mal parce qu'à l'époque je
me rappelle que les guignols me taper
formant sur la tête et elle elle était
enceinte elle était furax elle en
souffrait beaucoup parce qu'elle
comprenait pas le second degré et elle
voyait que je dormais très peu la nuit
je faisais mon maximum en tant que papa
que je travaillais beaucoup vous le jour
et elle trouvait ça particulièrement
injuste mais j'avais beau et c'est lui
expliquer les seconds degrés ça passait
de leurs noms mais bon on s'est séparé
parce que voilà c'est une histoire
d'amour qui s'est terminé alors voilà et
puis après basse et c'est un peu le
déclin oui bah bien les choses à marie
france brière qui tente n 2 vous
demandez à faire autre chose que des
émissions pour la jeunesse qui est
normal briques moment où tony chard
j'imagine des talk-shows d'adultes bas
on m'avait parlé de deuxième partie de
soirée voilà c'était un travail et bien
sûr et puis de l'audience ayant explosé
on me dit éric nantel est resté à la
jeunesse le succès fuit celle
là vous rejoignez tf1 à nouveau et vous
remplacez corbier dans le club dorothée
mais c'est la dernière année du traité
pour la dernière année dorothée
d'ailleurs n'avait pas compris je me
souviens la première réunion de travail
et le made in me qu'est ce que tu fous
là elle comprenait pas parce que tout le
monde essayait de quitter le navire à
l'époque il était de bon ton de
cracher sur dorothée et moi je débarque
et c'est pas vous quitter la télé
finalement c'est la télé qui vous qui
donnent certains examens oui on va plus
rien proposer aux besoins j'ai travaillé
sur beaucoup de projets qu'on lisait pas
très honnêtement j'ai demandé des
rendez-vous au mort serait poliment où
on ne recevait pas au final
on va plus rien proposé donc j'ai repris
j'ai pris un autre chemin il ya
aujourd'hui donc on l'a vu dans le sujet
vous avez donc ce magasin de chaussures
un besoin sont bien sûr très heureux
avec 1100 marque évident de la chance
oui ok le prothésiste c'est pas voulu
toucher
c'est trop c'est trop jeune il est
nostalgique de alors d'époque non pas du
tout j'ai vécu des choses tellement bien
et fantastique pour
en quelques années j'ai fait la chanson
j'ai fait la télévision j'ai fait du
théâtre
j'ai fait des téléfilms j'ai fait
des séries donc oui quand je regarde ça
c'est beaucoup de bonheur et des
souvenirs extraordinaires aucune
amertume j'étais à refaire et qu'est-ce
que vous ne seriez pas pareil
j'aurais au départ au tout départ quand
dominique ancien donc acquitter antenne
de provenir sur tf1
[Musique]
j'aurais accepté la proposition de canal
+ parce que pendant plusieurs mois
j'avais alain de graisse
qui m'appelait très souvent pour me eric
rejoins nous sur canal+ oui et pourquoi
pas et j'ai dit non parce que dominique
ancien a peut-être un petit peu plus
forcer les choses même un petit peu plus
bousculé pour que je reste avec elle sur
tf1 et alain de grèce mais plutôt laissé
faire simav un peu plus bousculé je
serais allé sur canal+ voilà mais bon
après faut jamais regretter
sur votre tombe quelle épitaphe vous
voudriez inscrire avec heureux salut les
canaris oui
bah merci avec ses très heureux de la
nuit la lumière sur vous merci beaucoup
merci à vous merci des cours est sûr de
ne rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous
il m'était impossible eux